hey everyone it's sarah with registered
nurse RN comm and in this video i'm
going to show you how to load a Lancet
device as a nursing student you will
need to know how to load a Lancet device
especially whenever you're teaching
diabetics how to check their blood sugar
and plus in the hospital setting you may
have to load a Lancet to buy a lot of
hospitals though have their own little
prefilled Lancet devices where you don't
actually have to put it together but
it's always good to know how to do this
now if you are newly diabetic or you're
just wanting to check your blood sugar
I'm going to this video help you out too
because I'm going to show you how to do
this so let's get started okay you're
going to need your Lancet device and
your landset before we get started I'm
going to go a little bit over these
little lancets because there are
different sizes you can get to use when
checking your glucose I'm generally
thirty which is what this lancehead is
is good enough to get a good prick on
your finger but they also have sizes
like 27 gauge 28 gauge 32 gauge and 33
gauge all this is is that it's a number
that represents the size of the needle
now the smaller the number the larger
the needle so a 27 gauge is a larger
needle than a 30 gauge so just pick
accordingly you have really thick skin
you probably need a bigger gauge needle
which would be a smaller number so
that's a little bit about lancets
now let's load our device all devices
are typically the same and they work the
same and what you do is they have an
area where you can twist the cap off and
expose the area where this little
landset is going to go now this area
right here notice when I push it in I
can hit this button right here and it's
going to engage disengage the needle and
whenever I do that that means it's going
to poke your finger so that's just how
that works it's usually always good to
see how the mechanism behind something
works because it helps you understand it
better so now let's put our Lancet in
the device and it has little grooves
that's going to line up with this groove
right here I don't know if you can see
it there might be a glare but there's a
groove right here and it's going to fit
in
side of where the land set is and it
just slides right down in there and what
we're going to do is we're going to go
ahead and engage the needle because you
don't want to engage it while you've
exposed your needle because you're going
to increase your chances of
contaminating the needle and getting
poked yourself so go ahead and just poke
it in and we're going to twist this cap
off to expose the needle and needles
right there it's very very very small
and we're going to gently put the cap
back on and always remember to engage
your needle whenever you put the cap
back on and it's ready to use but
there's still one more step we have to
do now on your device whenever you're
first using it you're going to have to
pick a setting and there's these little
numbers right here it goes from 0 to 5
some devices go up til 10 but all this
is is telling us how deep this needle is
going to go into our finger now here
look in your user guide for your land
set because it'll tell you the different
depths but generally this is how it
works 1 to 2 is for people who have
really thin skin if you're taking
corticosteroids or your hands bruise
easy your fingers bruise is easy you
just have thin skin you probably want to
use a 1 to 2 setting if you have like
average skin like most people you're
young 3 to 4 is probably the best but 5
or higher if you are like a man or woman
who work a lot with your hands you have
very callous fingers you probably want
to use a deeper setting because if you
use a 3 or 4 one or two it's probably
barely I'm going to graze the skin
you're not going to get a good prick so
always adjust your settings ok so that
is how you load your Lancet device now
be sure to check out my video on how to
use the Lancet device on how to check
your blood glucose using a glucometer